THAT.
>>
>> YOU SAID I'M NOT A POINT
GUARD, I'M A KILLER.
TELL ME FIVE GUYS PLAYING RIGHT
NOW THAT YOU'RE LIKE, THEY'RE
KILLERS.
>> STEPH CURRRRY, KAVEN DURANT,
JAMES HARDEN -- JAMES HARDEN --
>> WHAT'S THE SMILE FOR?
>> BECAUSE I KNOW A LOT OF
KILLERS.
BRADLEY BEAL IS A KILLER.
OH, DAME.
DAME IS THE KILLER.
>> CERTIFIED.
>> DANE IS A MONSTER WITH IT.
STEPH IS JUST BAD AS HELL.
BUT DAME JUST A RUDE MOTHER --
HE'S JUST RUDE.
HE'S DISRESPECTFUL.
HE JUST DO ANYTHING, PASS
HALF-COURT AND LET IT FLY.
LIKE NO FEAR.
HE'S NOT JUST A KILLER, HE'S A
SERIAL KILLER.
>> BIG SHOUT OUT TO DAME.
SPEAKING OF DAME, I ALSO ASKED
DAME IF HE HAD A QUESTION FOR
YOU AND I HAVE ONE FROM HIM, AS
WELL, WHICH MAKES MEHINK OF
ANOTHER ONE OF YOUR QUOTES WHICH
IS WHEN SOMEONE ASKED YOU ABOUT
COACHING YOU SAID I AIN'T
COACHING BECAUSE I DON'T WANT TO
COCOACH N MOTHER -- THAT MAKE
MORE MONEY THAN ME.
>> RIT.
>> DOES THAT STAND?
>> YEAH.
IT'S LIKE I ALWAYS HAVEHE -- I
HAVE THE UTMOST RESPECT FOR
COACHES IN THE NBA.
BUT COACHES WORLDWIDE, BUT IN
THE NBA IT'S TOTALLY DIFFERENT.
YOU HAVE ALL OF THESE GUYS
MAKING ALL THIS MONEY, EVERYBODY
ON THE TEAM MAKING MORE MONEY
THAN YOU.
AND YOU'RE ABLE TO BRING THESE
GUYS TOGETHER AND GET THEM TO
PLAY THE RIGHT WAY AND HAVING
THEM ALL WITITH THE SAME MIND-S
AND THE SAME GOAL IN THEIR HEAD
AND THEY BUY IN IT TO ULTIMATEL
WIN A CHAMPIONSHIP.
THAT'S POWER AND THAT'S RESPECT.
WHEN YOU'VE GOT THESE GUYS.
THEY PROBABLY FEEL LIKE THEY'RE
SUPPOSED TO BE THE MAN.
BUT SOMEHOW, SOME WAY, TO MAKE
IT ALL WORK, THEHEY FIT IN A RO,
PLAY THEIR ROLE AND ALL THE
SUCCESS COM